and again remember percentage of their
readers are ultra wealthy people who are
like yeah great I want to have a home on
on the East Coast that I can park my
private plane in and that'll be one of
my Hubs
and I'm pretty sure okay I don't know
the exact numbers on this but I can
triangulate a little bit I think they've
done at least 25 million in pre-sales on
this thing that is crazy it could be it
could easily be double that but um but
that is a a really awesome and
impressive like way to take this Niche
hobby take find a find a kind of media
publication that that works and go
content to Commerce
[Music]
I have a I have some stuff for today you
have something that I know about that
I've kind of mentioned but I mentioned
it without saying their name
Craig Fuller now we can't mention it did
you get permission from uh about this uh
yeah um I think so so we got uh some of
this is public but let's let's talk a
little bit about this okay so
there's this there's this business
called uh flying magazine or flying mag
and
um so when you look at it you're like
okay well what is this and so basically
the story is there's a guy who bought
this magazine called Flying mag and
flying mag produces this beautiful
magazine amazing photos and if you're a
flying or Aviation Enthusiast you will
love this magazine he bought it for like
I think
like
not quite 10 million but a little under
that so maybe somewhere between let's
call it five to ten million dollars my
guess is a fraction of that I think it
was closer to one do you have any
anything I've got a little Source here
saying hi seven figures so let's Okay
Okay assume the source is correct okay
so
um
but then I was like well where did this
person get high seven figures to go drop
on a magazine that seems like a pretty
indulgent purchase for somebody unless
they have a lot of money so he started a
company before that called Freight waves
which uh basically is like a data
company for the freight shipping
industry so they're like a uh a price
reporting company so they they provide
data that shippers and freight companies
use to um you know inform themselves on
what's going on in the market they also
have a SAS tool so they kind of have
like a media side which is the you know
content that they're producing that's
pricing information and then they have a
SAS business called sonar that's in it
and they've released a public press
release so you can kind of see his
numbers I saw they did that that's very
weird that they did that yeah they're
not a public company but they sort of
like did a public report and I'm not
sure what the agenda was like I think
I'm just sort of naive here I don't know
I normally this is we want somebody to
buy us or we want to raise money
um or we're prepping to go public but
it's I don't think it's either any of
those three uh because of what they said
so they basically reported uh 13 million
in revenue for a quarter so let's call
it let's just extrapolate that out in a
straight line so roughly 50 million a
year in Revenue
um it wasn't a lot in profit so it was
like you know
um one or two million in ebitda in the
quarter or something like that so let's
say that this business is making I don't
know four to eight million a profit a
year but it's probably 70 a year it's
growing physically almost and it's been
around I think for a little while
um so so you know it's done well they
had 28 million in cash just like it on
the books on the balance sheet so you
know the business was in in a healthy
spot so I think Craig starts Freight
waves he then separately buys flying mag
one of the interesting things about
flying mag is that if you think about
who are the readers of a niche magazine
like this you have
two categories
Uber nerds and Uber nerds who are rich
because you know you got to be kind of
nerdy about this hobby if you're going
to be like reading about this like we
had a guy once who we hired as an
engineer that used to had an app on his
phone where he would listen to the uh
what's called Air Traffic Control he
would just tune into the frequency of
air traffic control listen to it at
lunch and like I gotta tell you
never had a worse lunch with anybody in
my life dude me him and his phone on
with air traffic control was our lunch
and I was like you know hey man I'm
gonna go back for seconds and then I'm
gonna go kill myself so you'll see later
this has been horrible thanks I do I do
that with the uh I do that with the
police scanner you ever deal with the
police scanner at least police look
there's a show called cops there's no
show called
safe Landings because that's all Air
Traffic Control there's no there's no
show called which way is the wind
blowing but there
babe called that there is a video game
where all you are is an air traffic
controller
yeah fair enough okay
so anyways the back to back to my flag
mag story so
a big percentage of the readers are like
rich people with private planes or like
you see this a lot in tech for some
reason like uh my buddy furcon did this
sold this company immediately starts
signs up for flying lessons wants to get
his Pilot licensed to like go fly this
like you know five-seater or six-seater
or two-seater plane
um they love that Hobby
and there's a really expensive hobby
um
so one thing that they did recently that
I think is really smart is have you
heard about this this community building
in Atlanta so he told me I'm not going
to steal your thunder but he told me
what he was gonna do and he all he goes
I'm flying from New York to go see this
property I'm looking at and I'm flying
my private plane do you want to come
with me and I ended up not going because
I had to go up to Teterboro so in New
Jersey and then fly back down to Atlanta
to see the spot with them but he asked
me to go with him and I almost did it
and he was and so uh I've known about
this for about a year and a half now
yeah that's great so and so the the
interesting thing is they're basically
building a community in Atlanta and I
think the reason people build these
communities is like there's like a a
what's it called like a landing strip
like in the middle of the neighborhood
so you could park your plane and if you
want to take off you could just like go
take off it's like like the driveway of
the community is like a a landing strip
and correct it's it's a it's a so it's a
country club with go with homes around
the golf course but instead of a golf
course it's a landing strip
that's exactly what it is so it's a it's
a country club Country Club for flying
and so you purchase I forget how much a
piece of plot of land costs and then
they build a build you a home and now
you are part of this Aviation community
right and so they pre-sold the the plots
of of land are the plots of uh for the
homes in this community so they find
this kind of bare ground or whatever
they start pre-selling the plots and
again remember a percentage of their
readers are ultra wealthy people who are
like yeah great I want to have a home on
on the East Coast that I could park my
private plane in and that'll be one of
my Hubs
and I'm pretty sure okay I don't know
the exact numbers on this but I can
triangulate a little bit I think they've
done at least 25 million in pre-sales on
this thing that is crazy it could be it
could easily be double that but um but
that is a a really awesome and
impressive like way to take this Niche
hobby take find a find a kind of media
publication that that works and go
content to Commerce right this is the um
what's the churning group churning group
believes in this the content to Commerce
so they they did uh which is what
hodinki did hodinky did this for watches
right watch blog for super high-end
watches well guess what as soon as you
start selling watches that business I
think Kevin Rose came on this podcast
and said it went from one or two million
a year in Revenue to 100 million when
they flipped that switch and started
actually selling the watches that they
had been talking about for 15 20 years
and um so content to Commerce is this
kind of like really interesting play and
I think that uh this is a great example
of it being done well yeah look you have
BuzzFeed doing it with stuffed animals
which is pretty lame you know they did
it with with houses and this is baller
uh Craig told me about this about a year
and a half ago and I was like this is
very bold and he was explaining it to me
and he was very confident and it was
like no big deal and I was thinking
about this and I was like I don't know
this kind of seems like a really big
deal to me we should do well I was like
I don't think you're gonna be able to
pull this off well I didn't say that but
in my head I was like this is ridiculous
he totally did they totally pulled it
off
we um we did this way back in the day I
think you would said something you were
like ads are lame or this before HubSpot
bought the podcast so it was basically
like ads are lame we're selling ads for
the podcast but like what would be a
better business for for my first million
to do and I think at the time people
were like you should create like a
wework like a branded version of wework
or like a white label like uh co-working
space or something like that which
sounded crazy but I actually think that
there was a version of that that that's
as true like basically if we just bought
like a eight unit or 16 unit apartment
building
um in San Francisco but it was only you
could only go rent there if you were
part of our community or you could buy
units there it would be part of our
community something like that could work
uh because people would rather live in a
community of like-minded people than a
community of absolute strangers I think
there's a huge number of people that
would do that and so then you get into
the real estate game these units in San
Francisco go for you know a million and
a half two million dollars on average
you know they so so you could do these
things where you you know in theory
every a brand like ours could also do
that and say yeah if you want to be
around other entrepreneurs other
business people who are you know share
this kind of like this ethos that we
have then uh you know you could do that
but there's a problem which is you and I
I don't know about you me I wasn't even
bold enough till I consider that I
thought that was stupid now I've got a
little bit more experience and I kind of
understand like our pull a little bit
now I actually think that that could
work but at the time I was like that's
ridiculous there's there's no way that
would work
dude my brain is like a metal detector
that's just looking for something that's
going to scare me to do I'm just like
where can I get the maximum thrill the
business thrill like we're gonna get the
maximum reward plus I'm down with the
risk and saying that like if I said out
loud that I was doing this that I think
would get other people's attention but
it would also make me a little scared
because I don't know exactly how to do
it like I am very attracted to
these ideas and there's that's not
always a good thing I think that's a bad
thing in many cases but uh but I'm I
hear that and I want to run into that
fire a little bit whereas I think you
hear that you're like there's a fire why
would I run no no no no no now now I'm
more comfortable because I've seen some
I've seen like well if you do this this
and this the odds of some type of uh
return is is positive but like before I
was still kind of understanding like
that mechanics of business and like
investing and things like that now I
actually do see it we're like the
Opposites uh we're like the opposite I
get excited by that weird kind of like
kind of half figured out thing and
you're like well why don't you know I
want to figure it out first but then
once you do figure it out you're like
you're like go and you just execute and
you're like locked in and you just you
just freaking go on that opportunity
whereas I'm like oh this is cool and
it's kind of figured out all right cool
um like I'll kind of go there but oh
there's this other interesting thing
over here that's like you know I figured
out and I I'm not as good at the lock-in
you get bored after you figured out the
puzzle exactly yeah exactly for me I
have to figure out a little bit more and
like I want like a higher certainty that
the puzzle pieces are even gonna be able
to fit together you know what I'm saying
right right exactly um but then once the
puzzle's done you're you're like my
puzzle I love this puzzle dude this is
my puzzle I'll tell you an example so uh
Sean and I are going to Vancouver
Wednesday I think and we're doing this
little uh meet up with us and Andrew
Wilkinson and this wasn't even that well
organized like they've done a good job
of it but like there's no Maybe not
maybe it well organized isn't the right
word because that sounds insulting it
was just kind of low-key like we just
have like a type form that you have to
sign up for and that's it and then you
pay 50 bucks to show up and I think you
get a refund if you show up I think
they're doing it to like guarantee seats
like the people listening to the Pod if
they say how do I sign up I don't even
know where to I don't know where to go
uh we're doing a meet up but it's in
stealth mode for no reason I don't know
I don't know what the organizer guys
doing but it doesn't make any sense to
me it doesn't make any sense to me yo um
what's the venue and date and time
oh man we're it's all coming together
we're working on it it's like yeah I
don't know I don't know this fire
Festival what's happening here and then
he they refunded the money and I'm like
well I could have used that money on
like my flights and hotel I wish I wish
you know like I'm paying money to go and
do this it would have been cool because
like the thing it made like 50 or 100
Grand I'm like you know give me like 3
000 to pay for my stuff but uh when I
when I kind of like realized that we
were able to pull off some of this stuff
I'm like oh hey we can get people the
the thing with media what is if you can
get people to buy [__] or leave your
home so like if you say I'm gonna be at
this location at this time the if you
were able to get people to do that that
means you have pull and once every once
in a while when we pull that off then
I'm like oh we could have pulled this
off something like this or we still
could we still can and then I I I I
start to believe it
yeah that's interesting actually that's
a good metric because um I've been
trying to think about on the content
side I'm like you know I want to set a
goal because I think uh I work better
when I have a goal
you have to give context the context is
Sean is now he's considering or planning
or doing to go harder on creating
content yeah yeah exactly uh sounds lame
so don't even say those words content
creator sounds like lame I'm gonna come
up with my own words but like yeah the
idea is hey I like doing this thing
where I get to just like learn about
stuff talk about it and people seem to
like it podcast is one version of that
the newsletter is another version Etc
and um anyways the point is I was like
what's a what's a good goal for this and
I was like oh a million uh 10 million
subscribers fans no what do I want here
and I was like and then I was like
intuitively there's something more like
um that Kevin Kelly thing the true fans
thousand true fans where it's like uh he
wrote this blog post that's amazing
that's called a thousand true fans
basically says
if you can have if you can have a
thousand true fans a true fan being
somebody who would pay a hundred dollars
across the course of a year they'll buy
your shirt they'll show up you know for
your event they'll buy your tickets
they'll do whatever because they really
like your stuff and like you know for an
artist if you're somebody who's just
creating a thousand people who are
willing to pay a hundred bucks sounds
kind of achievable it doesn't that's not
like I'm gonna be the next you know
Justin Bieber or whatever
um and it's a hundred grand and like you
could make a living doing what you love
if you get to that point that was like
one of the original things that I think
inspired a lot of content creators
online and um I was like oh maybe
something like true fans but how do you
measure a true fan I guess it's this
hundred dollar spend thing but I think
this thing you're saying is actually
true which is uh it's like a test it's
like if I just tweeted hey I'm hanging
out at this coffee shop right now in San
Francisco
how many people would show up and like I
think three years ago that answer was
zero to zero to two you know like maybe
just my actual friends who I hadn't
caught up with in a while
um
you know now I don't know what that
number would be but probably what do you
think if I did that no idea well if you
know thousands would be crazy but if I
was like no hang out here all day so
it's not like if you came into that
window if you gave it a two-week window
or a two-week notice a two to four week
notice I think you know I'm saying same
day I'm just I'm gonna be here all day
swing by if you're around 50 to 100 I
bet 5200 yeah exactly and I think that
there's a that's probably that's great
that's that's amazing there's some point
where it's like uh the coffee Shop's
like what the [__] is happening uh
there's like there's too many people
here guys what what is this there's some
point where you break the coffee shop
and I'm like okay there's some way of
testing that because
I think what most people go is for reach
and they get really tricked by these
platforms that are like yeah your video
got 95 000 views and it's like cool
um how many of them actually watch this
versus just swiped by it or if they want
like do how many of those 95 000 people
know your name how many of them know
anything about you how many of them care
about you right like and so I think what
most people do is they they just take
what they're fed and they're fed
basically the most large vanity useless
number and I think for any business you
want to find not the vanity metric but
the true metric that actually shows
um like the level of Engagement you have
the level of love that your product has
and so um and different business
different companies have like different
ways of looking at this like Facebook
back in the day one of their metrics
that mattered was they were like yeah of
all of our signups 50 of them use this
every day
and that became this thing that was like
okay it's not that they have the most
signups like Myspace has way more but
man this Facebook thing like have to use
half of the total signups are using it
every single day that's gotta mean
something and the people that were able
to identify that inside the company and
as investors got mega mega Rich whereas
other people were just chasing like a
total user count number but they didn't
really like have a good way to measure
it so I think there's something to like
finding the real metric that matters at
the hustle what did you guys use because
you could have just said subscribers
right but that wasn't like quite the
that wasn't just the thing like do you
have any examples of finding the real
metric that matters dude I we we would
just do replies and so every once in a
while I would purposely either write
about something that was a bit
controversial or I would purposely have
typos and I would just see how many
people reply and say that they saw a
typo or at the very bottom of the email
and I told you to do this and I think
you did do it I would say
um where where what city are you in
right now send me is or I would say um
I'm working from this brand new desk
it's called this I love it take take a
picture of your workspace let me see it
and it would be just how many people are
going to take a picture and reply back
to the email and there was a time where
at the very bottom of the email we said
we're gonna send out stickers to
everyone that replies and we got like 10
000 replies so we had to like mail at 10
000 stickers and so we would do little
things like that where and this we got
like 10 000 replies on like a hundred
thousand subscribers and so I remember
like anytime we get a reply from an
email that's a that's a really good sign
right and like I see this all the time
with newsletters now because substack
has this feature where if you subscribe
to one newsletter like I read something
I'm like yeah I like this I subscribe it
pops up this full screen thing which is
just like Sean recommends these five
newsletters and there's only one button
and you're just like uh okay next if you
hit that and now you're subscribed five
newsletters and you can see people on
substack they're like wow my new my
growth is crazy I'm hitting 100 000 than
200 thousand three hundred thousand
dollars dude it's all [__] and
substance like this is awesome when
they're showing this I'm sure in their
investor presentation look at this now
we drive the majority of subscriber
growth for our newsletters there's a
network effect here it's like no it's
not a network effect it's a giant screen
where people click next like I used to
do this with our mobile apps it's like
oh if I want to if I want this app to
grow let me just pop up a screen where
it's your entire contact list everybody
pre-checked there's one big button that
says next and there's a tiny black X
that's like hidden in the top left
corner if you could see that you're
gonna skip it and like everybody wants
to skip it but two out of two out of
every 10 people are just going fast and
they're just gonna hit the button and
they just spammed all of their contacts
and guess what my app goes viral is it
really viral are they sharing it because
they like this product no they're
sharing it because I tricked them into
spamming basically and substack does the
same thing they basically trick people
into subscribing to these newsletters in
my opinion they I'm sure they would
disagree and say no no no people just
really want to be referred Five News
newsletters every time they've subscribe
to one I I don't believe that for a
second
um this happens with podcasts there's a
very popular business podcast I like the
guy but I think his numbers are BS it's
uh you know should I say the name I
don't know if I should say the name but
like do it
uh let's just say
it's not a 30 minute VC it's a little
less than that
I'll leave it to you actually
no he's a he's a great guy and he's done
a great job building his podcast up but
he'll tweet out these things where he'll
be like 2 million two million people
listen to last week's episode with this
person and I'm just like dude there's
just no way in hell that's Joe Rogan
numbers that's
there's not two million people I know we
we we have a podcast I can see where we
are in the ranks I can see where he is
in the ranks I know other easy reviews
the charts you can look at the views you
can just see the cult following of
certain things like if you said you know
the all-in podcast is getting a million
views per episode I'd be like I think
that's true I think that they they
really tapped into something yeah you
could see the YouTube numbers you could
you could think about where where the
podcast charges I think it's doing at
least a million probably closer to two
per episode they do once a week it's
super high quality it's got a broad
appeal the numbers the data matches up
to that signal
um
but when you're like oh dude yeah I get
2 million per episode for my super you
know my talk with the third least
well-known partner at this fund I'm just
like there's no no chance and I think I
even asked him once I was like dude how
are you getting these numbers that
sounds like off the charts for what like
a a business or Tech podcast of of this
you know size could do
and he's like oh yeah we have a big
audience in Asia or wherever and I'm
just like oh okay well
I've been in the internet game long
enough to know like
like dude I bought my first 5 000
Twitter followers right like I I know
that you could get a you can get any
number by doing anything on the internet
and it doesn't mean anything especially
for something like podcasts which is
like newsletter subscribers it's like
the hardest thing ever you click once
and now you're a a consumer of
everything else like nobody could even
measure on podcasting if anybody's
actually listening to these things and
so
yeah I can go get a bunch of people to
click subscribe one time and it will
auto download my feed every time I
release a new episode like there was a
guy uh Nathan matka that was doing this
too he was like we get this many
downloads per month and I was like oh
wow a couple million downloads a month
that's pretty good huge yeah
um what do you do and basically he was
like and I I when I talked to him I was
like he's like hey welcome to the show
he's going like Hyper Speed five minutes
the podcast was over and I was like this
is a five minute episode he's like yeah
sorry I gotta hop to the next one I was
like how many of these you record in a
day he's like I record eight of these a
day and then we release like whatever
who's on some crazy schedule and then I
did the math and I was like oh he has
like 7 000 subscribers but he just
releases huge volume of Random episodes
of these five minute episodes and so his
total monthly number
because podcast is just like you know if
you just do downloads it just adds up
all your episodes times your number of
subscribers you can have a small number
of subscribers and do a huge number of
download a huge number of episodes and
get a big download number and so people
I think use these vanity metrics all the
time and they're BS so I I'll bring this
up because we're discussing it but I
didn't research it fully but have you
heard of uh parcast it's like my name
but cast so parcast have you ever heard
of that are you are you spinning off
your own solo did the brand makeup band
break up and you're doing your own
episode
I I wish I invented this so it's a guy
named Max Cutler I think he's our age I
think he's uh like 31 32 33. so this guy
named Max Cutler created this thing
called parcast and the whole idea of it
is it's a podcast network but they um
they only have a crime a true crime and
I'm a weirdo you want to know what I
listen to every night there's two
podcasts I listen to every night the
first one is just called serial killers
so it it's a it's it's just a bunch of
podcasts about serial killers I I can
tell you all I gotta I got I got my
fantasy uh League of serial killers you
know with Ted buddy as the quarterback
and then there's another one called you
know it's it's this one's fitting for
going to sleep it's called deathbed
confessions so it's people who confess
about a crime they did when they're
dying so it's just nice it's the best so
this guy started this and it's all
scripted so it has like voice actors and
it's all scripted stuff he bootstrapped
this podcast company which is unheard of
and he sold it to Spotify for 200
million dollars after only maybe five
years and uh him and his dad owned the
whole company his dad was in radio and
so his dad was like a radio announcer or
something like that and uh they are
producing something like 30 or 40
podcasts a day like episodes and they're
all highly produced stuff and it's
amazing have you not heard of this uh
heard of this business I've heard of
this brand once before I didn't realize
that they I didn't really I didn't know
the business side of it I didn't know
that they had bootstrapped it and sold
it to Spotify but I really I like True
Crime I don't know where to start just
like so many True Crimes and a bad one
is like such a waste of time but um yeah
I've seen some of their shows because I
go sometimes look in the browse section
for for like you know a good True Crime
dude so true crime if you go and look at
so it's a good one of theirs if you look
at I like serial killer serial killers
do death bed confessions is awesome I'll
send you a good death back confession
one they're so awesome and True Crime
it's uh if you go to the podcast uh app
and you look at like what are the top
episodes or shows it's always like 30 or
40 True Crime and which is it's mostly
women who listen to it and it's all we
and so like a dateline I told you about
this Dateline from NBC which is a show
that's been around for 20 or 30 years at
this point it's still usually a top
podcast every single week and so these
True Crime folks they kill it and this
guy bootstrapped this company
um to a I think it was a hundred million
cash and then a hundred another 100
million earn out all off of these True
Crime podcasts he killed it it's a
really interesting story I'm gonna have
to I'll dive deep and do some better
research on it but I was reading about
it uh this weekend it's it's a pretty
amazing outcome this guy had
so I just read an article this might be
maybe wrong or maybe you're wrong I
don't know Spotify confirms it paid 56
million for podcasts or podcast sorry uh
then maybe I got my numbers wrong I
think it was 56 and then another like 75
outcome it was a nine figure uh uh
another attention there was a retention
according to the podcast Wikipedia which
reads as if Matt Max Cutler the founder
wrote it it's very like congratulatory
uh it it says there's like a huge
turnout
yeah I don't know if I trust anyone that
does True Crime by the way uh these guys
are natural storytellers and like liars
dude all right I've got an interesting
thing to bring up this is a uh something
that we talked about a while ago I think
you brought this up in 2020 or 21 I
forget right when we were recording in
the original hustle office so do you
remember that company crumble that you
brought up
yeah well first of all I love a good I
told you so so I'm already I'm already
glowing uh yeah dude crumble cookies
crumble cookies so when you originally
told me about it the story was something
like these two brothers or two cousins
launched this thing and for some reason
in my head I'm thinking like a family
like cooking making cookies in their
like kitchen and they start this like
pandemic thing and it gets popular and
basically once a week they tweet out a
new menu and may have a drop you know
things that like typically Supreme does
or like these but they're doing it with
like outrageous flavored cookies well
that's not entirely true they what is
true is they do do these drops but it's
a massive business and some sources are
saying it's close to like 800 million a
year in revenue and the reason I saw it
was someone shared this on Twitter but
basically over the last like couple
months it's been growing and growing and
growing and so the other day it was like
the number fourth most downloaded app in
the week and so they have an app and so
their app now has 2.3 million ratings or
reviews with like with the 4.9 average
and what and right now they're opening
brick and mortar and they're opening a
new store every five days they have
something like 730 stores at the moment
it's one of the fastest growing chains
in America and so these guys check
listen to these numbers they have 800
000 followers on Twitter 3.4 on
Instagram 6.5 on Tick Tock 1.2 on
YouTube and they create these
commercials every single week for a new
cookie drop and it is crushing it these
guys are killing it it's so fascinating
I never in a million years thought this
was going to work as big as it has but
basically every Sunday at 6 PM they do
like a new drop in their app just spikes
and goes way up the charts and they are
they're up there with like Uber Eats and
all this stuff like that they're killing
it and so I remember you brought this up
and in my head I was like oh this is
like a little like Mom and Pop it sounds
cute like oh that's cute yeah like oh
your aunt make cookies that's nice yeah
no they're sharks they're killing it uh
and so you called that pretty early on
and uh now it's a franchise so here's
like here's some stats in 201 uh the
highest revenue store did something like
3.6 million other stores did uh the
average was like 1.6 million the store
with the highest net profit was 600 000
with the lowest being 33 000 with the
average profit of being around 350 000
and um according to uh the founders
Twitter they did over a billion dollars
in revenue and you have to come up with
150 000 and then you can open up a
franchise and they send you all this
traffic via their you know their
Instagram and their app super
fascinating business yeah this uh I
think in the franchise world this is
like the hottest franchise right now is
crumble cookie because
they're just exploding and they're just
super prop super popular right now I do
feel like this is not like uh the most
sustainable franchise like uh at one
point in time wasn't like I think I feel
like Froyo franchises were like growing
like crazy like this I don't know if it
was Pinkberry or whoever else like uh
you know there's these waves where this
becomes the the treat but like I don't
know how many people are gonna like
anything that's drop based there's a
natural fatigue that sets in for the
buyer and uh and there's like a vicious
cycle like drops when everybody's into
the drop get even more fun because it's
like the hunt and you've either got it
or you didn't get it and you feel
special but as soon as that starts as
soon as the drop fatigue starts to kick
in and now oh notifications there but if
I don't get it today I can go get it
tomorrow like as soon as the scarcity is
gone the drop like plummets in value and
so I think that that's a a challenge for
for something like this but I agree but
look here's the deal I have a you and I
have a friend who buys Broadband
companies so Broadband companies are
basically internet service providers and
a lot of people who are listening in the
city will have no idea what I'm talking
about but where I have my country house
I've got this Ranch way out in the
country and if you live out in the
country it's not like you're getting
like Spectrum or Google or Warner or
whatever the big service providers are
in New York City you're getting like a
small internet provider that you pay a
hundred bucks a month for and they
probably that company probably does 10
million in revenue and like 5 million in
profit and you and I have a friend who
goes out and buys these companies and
everyone says to him well what about
starlink yada yada and he was like yeah
they'll they'll come eventually but like
until then I'm making five million
dollars a year in profit so right with
uh with this cookie thing yeah maybe
they'll Plateau but a billion a year is
a nice Plateau I don't mind sitting in
that Plateau for a while and that's kind
of that's like how I feel whenever I
hear some of these stories like it's not
going to grow I'm like yeah that's cool
sorry I couldn't hear you the money
powder was spurring a little too loud in
my ears that goes back to me if anybody
asked me why I sold for 200 million you
get in a slap like you know just don't
ask don't ask us stupid questions dude
and and the founder uh one of the
cousins or one of the brothers they uh
he previously worked in Tech and he had
a Facebook app that got to like 120
million followers so these guys are like
viral guys they know how to do this but
interesting story yeah it looks like he
was director of product at ancestry
which is like one of the like uh it's
just one of the gems of internet
companies that's like really big but
nobody knows anybody who's like works
there or nobody nobody claims to use it
even though it's like really really
popular site and did a bunch of cool
like viral things and like basically did
a bunch of smart product stuff along the
way to like make that business work dude
ancestry's funny too because they're a
utah-based company and they're founded
by Mormons This Guy's first business
first business byu.com
you hear about this
on his LinkedIn byu.com was a social
network for Brigham Young University
students we we grew the network to
include Half the campus in a very short
amount of time but was ultimately
crushed by Facebook so he did this in
2005. I think Facebook launched 2004 and
so basically
he was doing the like you know the the
Harvard social network he was doing that
just on BYU's campus but like the
Facebook wave you know swallowed it but
that's you know you're putting that's
pretty impressive you're landing on on
the budding green right there if you're
if you're creating a social network back
in 2005 for college campuses like
God damn you were close to being on to
something you know like I'm not
surprised that this guy ended up being
really successful
no it's a really fascinating story
um but uh anyway what what where do you
want to go you want to drive can can I
can I oh yeah that story really quick
Ben has a story
so obviously you mentioned their Utah
company so of course I know uh well so
the story is
uh this guy adds me from Utah State
University uh looks like he's just
graduating or about to graduate uh I
have a bunch of mutual friends with him
on LinkedIn so I was like okay I'll do
this kid a favor I don't know what he
wants so I click add and he immediately
starts posting cringe like uh I'm
starting this company it's gonna be huge
and then he keeps posting stuff that's
like I don't know how to describe it
it's very um like Adam Grant or Dumber
like business like did you know that you
can increase your productivity by 20 by
having a team off-site so we're having a
hashtag team offside this weekend and uh
I was just like who is this kid he says
he's starting a Cookie Company what
honestly when they open their first
location I was like I'm amazed I didn't
think this kid would ever actually get
even a location open and uh and it was
Sawyer the the founder the CEO of uh of
crumble and uh this kid who just posted
cringe to my LinkedIn timeline
totally like breaks my frame I just
always assumed that if you're that Mega
cringe you won't win and now now I have
to consider the possibility that every
hashtag user could actually be a winner
because I'm doing a blanket rule
if you're a Mormon guy and you're
telling me you're going to start a a
cute cookie franchise I'm in I mean come
on
Mormon does Trump cringe so like if
you're Mormon
I have to I you know the checkbook's
already out I'm just waiting to hear you
know how many zeros I need to put my my
number here but that's based on the idea
so yeah you're right that that actually
overwhelms the cringe part because it's
like
this guy's gonna sell he's gonna this
person knows how to sell yeah the well
that sucks Ben yeah you missed out on
that one yeah I know I should have just
hit him up and like oh this looks really
cool but uh you know live and learn
I can find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
[Music]
um Sean I have a couple things what do
you want to do
um okay I have a quick little idea so I
was watching the Super Bowl and um
uh did you watch by the way
uh uh uh I watched the halftime show
yeah I watched it I watched no I uh I I
watched like quarter three who I wanted
to take you to figure out Rihanna was
pregnant during the halftime show
um
you know it was one of those things
where my wife loves her and like you
know you don't want to be rude when you
see a lady with a lump and you want to
like you know and I'm not going first
that's I'm not talking yeah yeah so I I
had her go first then I asked but she
was doing some pretty uh raunchy stuff
as a pregnant lady right I mean that was
like Oh I thought that was tame for
Rihanna that's like that was PG dude I'm
a Rihanna fan she's in my like top five
like most beautiful women on earth I'm
uh I'm on team Rihanna but when I
thought she was pregnant I uh it was
that was surprising I think she just had
a kid too
yeah
that's yeah she just had to get like
nine months ago I don't the math doesn't
even make sense to me in my head
whatever whatever I'm watching the
football game and um one thing you
notice if you're watching the game is
that when the chiefs were scoring they
were scoring with these like incredible
plays where the guy was just going
untouched into the end zone like dude
what was that thing where they like well
they did yeah like rig Around the Rosie
and then they like run to the line that
was crazy what is that but amazing that
they tried it right like that is uh that
was an awesome play so I was thinking
about it and I was like but it did stand
out they had the two or three touchdowns
where it was just like brilliant play
design right call and like totally
worked and then you know I I've gone you
know I love sports and I've watched tons
of sports documentaries and shows like
last chance you could just see the life
of a coach and a coach is like a really
specific character in my head like a
football coach at a high school college
or even Pro level is like it's the same
type of dude in most cases and their
life is football they live and breed
this [__] they're preparing all week for
you know the Sunday game and then they
start again the next week and they're
just like they just live in this
Playbook and the X's and O's they all
have the same value system about
toughness and grit and whatever and um
and I was like oh this is another job
that AI is going to replace because I
was like this is this is an AI problem
the problem of an offensive coordinator
in the NFL which is basically what play
should I call here to maximize you know
my expected return
and I think you can somebody's going to
build AI that basically ingests a bunch
of data that says in this situation
third down and seven
um you know maybe even take into account
the teams and the talent you know
equation this is the best play to run
with the highest expected value it's
basically like what Madden does when
Madden suggests like yeah run this play
but like yeah yeah that's a really good
version of Madden now that we have like
you know computers are geniuses and so
um so I'm pretty sure that there's
somebody's gonna build a
uh basically like a play caller AI play
caller that will help because these guys
are you just look they're literally
looking on a cheat sheet like you know
like like it's a open book exam or
whatever and it's like you can bring in
one eight by eleven piece of paper and
everyone's writing in like size two font
to squeeze as many things as I can on it
that's what these guys use when they're
calling plays and it's like they have
you know 10 seconds to pick the play
this is just a job that computers are
going to be better at and um it just
reminds me of like how crazy AI is gonna
be that like even these like total
non-tech situations not even big markets
but it's just going to be like when now
when humans play against a computer at
chess or or even you know go or poke or
whatever where the computer is just so
much better than the human that's what's
gonna happen in this play calling
situation it just kind of reminded me
about man AI is going to be going to be
nuts because it's going to take over all
these things that you wouldn't really
have expected or in the line of fire for
AI
is football as like you know there's
obviously the famous Moneyball thing
where he's like I don't care what who's
a superstar who's not I'm just going to
look at the math and we're just going to
pick people off spreadsheets
and then famously although I think this
is highly exaggerated chamoth was like
oh I'm gonna buy the Warriors and we're
going to do that same thing with
basketball so we're only going to shoot
threes or whatever I don't pay attention
but whatever their their stick is sorry
I'm ruining this but yeah and I but the
reason I have a feeling it's not true is
I have a feeling none of that team and
also like I think he said that though
right
uh I don't think so but um
but uh other people just in basketball
Daryl Mori famously was like the big you
know proponent of this the reason why I
don't believe that is I have a feeling
like teams were always doing this like
maybe it's one of those things where
like um
um like for example my favorite
copywriter he was like I wrote These
famous ads for the cat what's it called
the Casio watch and he's like we talked
about how we use space grade aluminum
and crystal quartz to make this watch
and he was like little do they know
every watch does that like that's just
like table Stakes like every single
watch but I'm gonna explain it because I
know that the audience doesn't know and
so like you have a guy saying like look
we use state-of-the-art technology and
it's like an Excel sheet that like
everyone else uses it's like yeah I
guess it's state of the art but anyway
we have a premium license to Microsoft
Excel
unlimited seats unlimited seats we do
not use the trial but is football the
same way where you could just follow the
math so there's actually there's
actually a great question there's a
Daryl Mori went on that guy uh I forgot
his name the invest invest like the best
guy Patrick
yeah he went on his spot actually it was
a really really great podcast if you
like sports and you like kind of
business stuff it was it's kind of an
amazing one he talks about like baseball
is basically the almost like the perfect
game for uh modeling like you could
basically because it's like stationary
it's like one pit one batter versus one
pitcher and um and then you know like
it's a like it's a contained problem is
it whereas in basketball you got five
guys on the on each team on the course
you got 10 guys all moving around free
form at any given time the ball is
moving like crazy it's much harder to
model but you can still model the
impacts of like one player in these
certain situations and so it's like the
data thing has had a pretty big impact
in basketball but less than it did in
baseball baseball was like a math became
a math equation basketball became more
of a math equation than it was before
but still it's never going to be perfect
it's too come complex and high school
there's too many variables to be to be
perfectly modeled out or whatever
um but still it was improved which is
why you see like they'll post like uh 20
years ago here's what the shot chart
looked like and it's just dots all over
the the chords like as you kind of
expect like people shoot from everywhere
and it's like here's what it is in 2023
it's like people only shoot layups or
threes because optimally like basically
a three is worth you know
whatever 150 more than a two but there's
percentage difference of shooting it is
only like you know you know five to
seven percent worse than a two pointer
or whatever so you know you get like way
higher expected value for shooting a
three so that's why all these teams
shoot threes now or layups they've tried
they tell their players don't shoot this
in between shot because it's the wrong
combo right
um so things like that and then he's
like football is going to be the hardest
one to to game because you have 11
players on each side and On Any Given
Play Everybody's moving in different
directions and you can't really figure
out like the net effects of this guy
running in this Lane what did that cause
this other guy to do you know it's much
harder to do
um but I think that's that's true at a
like
because the reason these general
managers care is because they're trying
to they're trying to like basically it's
like a stock picker it's like they're
trying to find undervalued assets so the
way you do that is you say this player
is not like yes his traditional stats
look like this but his game impact is
different because of whatever and so
you're trying to figure out the value of
the game but it's the game impact
because of locker room stuff and
Leadership or is it no no they're
looking at just the on the court
movement like you know in basketball for
example there's an assist if I pass you
the ball you score that's an assist but
if I pass you the ball I've I've made
the whole defense shift to me you pass
it to the next guy you get the assist
the stat sheet doesn't show that I
actually was the one who created this
whole play this opportunity by by caving
in the defense so the stat sheets like
the traditional statutes limited so what
these guys have done is figure out like
Advanced stats that like better
better show an individual player's
impact not including locker room stuff
and he's saying football is even harder
more players more movement more whatever
less plays total uh so you have a
smaller sample size
but I think that this play calling thing
is bigger bigger in football because in
basketball you don't call many plays
um but in football every play is called
in by the coach and so if you can make
the coach 20 more intelligent by
suggesting a better play that's gonna
like that's gonna shift the time you
know the balance of power towards that
that team because they're just gonna get
that many more first downs of touchdowns
so I think this is like I don't know
it's kind of like really really Niche
here but I think this is an example of
how uh AI is going to touch a bunch of
areas and kill a bunch of jobs you don't
expect bar shop you got something yeah
okay so last night the game was dictated
on that terrible call that
um you know the the
Eagles Defender you know got called on
like a pass interference that basically
made uh ruin the game Chiefs win that
should have been decided by AI ref like
why are there not AI refs why is any
call Up For Debate you know I agree well
there are in some sports like in tennis
they put a chip in the ball so like when
the ball lands out you see they always
like instantly cut to this like
silhouette of the ball as I it was out
or it was in and everybody's just like
it's unarguable and why is that because
they have a chip in the ball and a bunch
of cameras that triangulate it so they
can tell you exactly whatever dude but
that's so boring
well that's the problem because in
baseball you would have been like oh
great like the Umpire calls strikes by
squatting behind the catcher and trying
to like eyeball this like that's insane
for this billion dollar sport like why
why are they doing this and it turns out
if you just used computer to pick that
to like perfectly call pitches I guess
the the reasoning must be at a band
you've been been leaving might know
better but there must be something where
people preferred that their human had
the like final say here versus because
like the technology is there for a a
computer to call balls and Strikes
there's really no need for that umpire
anymore I'm not romantic to the early
part of the game I'm romantic to fist
fights that's what I want and that's the
best part about baseball is when like
they get mad at each other I mean that's
what I watch I don't watch any of that
other crap I want to see them fight
there's a demo I I sent this to Ben I'll
show it to you there's a demo of because
this there's actually a bigger problem
fighting like dude how many fights like
I don't know in the UFC fight this fight
this weekend did you think the right guy
won I thought he I thought the right guy
won but people were me too but a lot of
people did not people deny it's a big
problem with like it's these three
judges that are going to decide who won
the fight and um and it's like how do
you call it oh yeah how do you judge you
know if this guy made the wrong facial
expression it's like did he get hurt how
am I assessing damage here whereas
there's an AI demo of basically the like
um like the the Striking tracker where
it's like this guy did a left hook and
it landed with this like with this level
of of impact or this like clean like it
was deflected partially there or a clean
shot and they're like we should have
basically like perfect tracking of the
fight game but for you as a fan would
you want that would you want the
computer to basically say who won the
fight or do you want these three old
judges to to scribble a scorecard I want
the three old judges because uh that's
not a lot of fun I can't believe it a
lot but here's why first of all when you
watch WWF and W in like fake wrestling
WWE is called now the best part is when
they like hit the ref or they like
distract them like sometimes they'll
have like a hot girl come and distract
him and he turns around and then like
something bad happens and that's like
the best part of the show is like when
there's drama
um but also
um in UFC
um they have a new thing where they
measure uh aggression you know like
who's like pushing who's pushing the
plot
um and I think they do that so it's more
exciting and I don't know if you can
entirely measure like aggression with uh
AI but that's why I don't like it
um but uh no I I I'm okay with having uh
humans do it I think it makes it more
exciting more exciting we're talking
about it they're almost always like
they're they're only ever in the
conversation when they do it wrong right
like it's never more exciting because
man they really the refs really uh
added to the to the fight there by by
scoring it like they didn't they don't
they don't add anything they only
subtract when they screw it up uh I'm
I'm surprised you don't want like the
actual accurate uh score the only thing
that I want I want them to tell me the
scores of a fight in between rounds and
have that be the official thing because
I want I want the person to know when
they're going into round three or round
five that I'm down and if I don't knock
this guy out the fight's over and so
that would be the only change that I
would want I want them to know the real
score as it's going I got one more
random topic let's do one more even
though we're a little over time uh well
if you're gonna do one more are you
gonna do this guy this Ahmad that seems
media all right go for it yeah it is
kind of meaty but let's do like a fast
version of it so uh so this guy amjad
who's the founder of replit
um which is an awesome company uh is he
tweeted this out he goes you know
um some of the biggest companies that
were built Airbnb Uber
Etc
um were built because they took an
underutilized asset and were able to get
more utilization so for example Uber our
Airbnb said well there's extra there's
an extra bedroom in your house or extra
rooms you have extra space today it's
not doing anything but you could rent
that out and we could actually have more
rooms to stay in
um and more options for a customer and
that became Airbnb this multi-billion
dollar company and Uber is the same way
he goes what are some other
underutilized assets I think this is a
great you know framework for trying to
figure out you know where where a
Marketplace could be or where a uh um
and I think people were doing this maybe
five years ago seven years ago a lot
more there was like a people realized
this and started jumping on it and
that's why you got Wag the Dog Walker
app you know which becomes worth a
billion dollars in Airbnb and then and a
bunch of others
um and I have some examples here but but
what do you think about this framework
and uh what examples stand out to you
I think it's brilliant I see on here you
have stay-at-home moms one of the best
Com or one of my favorite companies that
have been eyeing is called squared away
and their whole Niche is
uh virtual assistants and the virtual
assistant is a military wife and that's
like for some reason in my head I think
they're gonna act a certain way which
who knows if it's true but I think
that's one of the best ways of like a
quote and under underutilized asset I
love that
um but the problem is a lot of people
like I knew a guy who started a thing
where you could do it was like
self-storage but in other people's
garages right and I'm like dude this is
the stupidest [__] I've ever heard of
and it was in fact really stupid and it
completely didn't work
um and so I think that a lot of people
approach us poorly yeah I think the the
there's a lot of things you can think of
like I know uh another one that people
have tried a bunch was like chefs so
it's like oh why do you only order from
restaurants like what if there's a lady
who lives Three Doors Down that makes it
amazing you know Thai red curry you
could just order for her and she would
get she you know she'd get revenue for
her cooking skill and then she could
deliver to you and it's closer and you
know wouldn't just be limited to
restaurants but it's like
a operationally these businesses are
usually absolutely brutal B there's like
a whole bunch of like safety and quality
concerns and like um uniformity of the
quality concerns that that come up so I
think that's that's another problem uh
and then the economics like uh people do
you know is there enough dollar value
for there to be you know for the
customer to pay the provider to get paid
and the middleman to get paid and the
delivery person to get paid like you
need enough value in the chain which is
why Airbnb works it's like a high ticket
thing uh there's one for uh versus
others and there's one for pools that I
hear is killing it
yeah yeah exactly share like rent a
swimming pool by the hour right because
I have a pool we're not using it 95 of
the time so if somebody could rent it
from us and we make a few hundred bucks
yeah yeah that's great
um I want to give you some of the best
answers that came from the thread so the
first the number one is cars so cars I
think are parked like 93 or 95 of their
time of the time and so once we have
self-driving cars
um that car shouldn't just stay parked
it should go go be a taxi for somebody
and earn you money so I think that's
like one of the big unlocks that people
you know people who know about this
they're like oh yeah that's obvious and
that's going to be a big deal but I
would say the majority of the population
doesn't realize
that your car is going to turn into a
worker for you
um and people are going to just you're
going to be earning Revenue when your
car is idle instead of just sitting in
your driver or your garage
dude get around which I used to use all
the time in San Francisco I think they
raised almost a billion dollars in
funding and they went public recently
ish their market cap as of right now 59
million dollars so wow no one quiet has
figured it out yet it looks like well
that's a little different that's still
rental cars this is going to be just
like no get around to other people well
yeah you're right you're right right
so so uh it is what Tesla is basically
betting on this is what elon's betting
on he basically is like your car is
going to go from a depreciate
depreciating asset to a revenue
generating asset for you which will make
the car worth five times more than it is
today
um once it once it's able to just run
all day for you and just go do rides
okay that's that's bold but that'd be
cool if it works out uh clean structured
data so basically there's a bunch of
data that in a bunch of different
companies just sitting around and if you
could kind of organize it and clean it
up
um that data is actually an asset that
can be used and like we talked about
earlier the freight waves company that's
doing pricing data
you know how many companies have pricing
data about like what they bought
recently how much it costs how what
volume and from what provider if that
was available in a structured way and
you could sell that to a middle like a
network like a data aggregator
um
you know that that becomes a valuable
asset that today is worth zero to the
company that has the data but it's not
doing anything with it and it's not
their main business to be able to do
something so I thought that was kind of
an interesting one
um dude someone wrote the Sun
yeah the Sun so they were like the sun
is basically providing all this energy
but until we have solar and batteries to
capture it uh it's massively
underutilized like we're getting free
energy from this giant you know uh
nuclear fusion reactor that's in the in
the sky or whatever uh but you have to
be able to capture it and store it and
uh it's underutilized for that reason
um another one I thought is kind of
interesting uh so fun one nightclubs
nightclubs are really like only useful
like you know for like five percent a
night time yeah you know at night on you
know Thursday Friday Saturday or
whatever
um what can we do and they're usually in
kind of prime real estate in cities and
um I've always thought it was cool when
I lived overseas in Indonesia they used
to take nightclubs and during the day
turn them into like Fitness day bars so
you'd go in the dance floor and the
mirrors would turn into basically like a
cardio session and then the bar would
turn into a smoothie bar and I was like
oh this is so smart they're getting like
double utility out of their nightclub
um I don't know why I've never seen that
in the United States for some reason
um so I think nightclubs is a fun one
and then another one that was on here
was a specialist Talent so like what's
that mean like think about somebody
who's like a really great 3D animator or
something like that so like if a company
hires you that's great uh but I would
actually say like you doing the thing
you're world class at you're probably
only doing like 10 to 15 of your time
when you're in a big company
um a lot of your time gets spent sort of
like waiting for approvals or feedback
or doing meetings or doing whatever
other stuff that's around it there's
probably a case to be made that like
people with really specialist Talent you
know Financial modeling or design or
whatever
they would be better off being freelance
to companies but it would need to the
market needs to be more liquid and
fast-paced than it is today like um you
you would need like like Naval has
talked about this he says the future of
work is basically like Ocean's 11. it's
small teams of people that are within
each team there's like highly
specialized you know that guy's the the
guy who's a pickpocket and this guy's
the guy who can break codes and this
guy's the guy who can do acrobatics
whatever like the ocean is 11 that's
what they do there's a highly talented
Specialists they gang up together to go
on this mission for a heist they then
they split the money they go in their
way they rest until they get the next
call and he's like that's what and he's
like that's what work is going to be
it's going to be PODS of people that
work well together highly specialized
they're going to get a beep up they're
going to wake up in the morning they're
not gonna have a job they're gonna wake
up in the morning and check their phone
for possible missions they could go on
they could choose to do none of them and
just chill that day or take one because
they're like oh that's a juicy Bounty
they could go do that mission when
they're done the employer rates them
like like an Uber ride like five stars
you rate the employer five stars the the
money gets paid out to everybody's cell
phone and you go on your way and you do
you wait till the next job and I just
thought that was a really sexy view of
the future it hasn't happened quite yet
but like you could see like I guess Uber
kind of works like that and I guess
there's like you know taskrabbit and
these other things that kind of work
like that and I guess freelancing is
becoming more popular maybe this is
maybe we are shooting in that direction
I hate when people make these claims
like this is the future of blank like if
you say that like the Futures electric
car yeah I buy that but if you say the
future of work is like Ocean's 11 my
reply to that is like no maybe the
future of criminals is ocean 11. but
like that's not like it's like the
future of people getting money is to rob
banks no maybe like a group of people
will do that but I just don't think that
like but why okay take the Ocean's 11
analogy out right like yeah that's
leading you to bank because what's wrong
with the actual premise
because I think most people now it's
like saying well most people are just
gonna freelance no maybe 30 of America
will but I think that 60 to 70 of
America they want to go to work at nine
they want to get off at four or five and
they want to play softball that's what
they want to do they don't want to like
go on a heist where they like are having
some exciting Mission they just want to
clock in and clock out and do the same
thing every day maybe we think that's
cool maybe think our listeners think
thinks it's cool but I think when Naval
says something like that I think that he
is in this small bubble and although
he's smart and gets a lot of things
right I think it's too grandiose to say
this is the future of work and I think
it's really dumb like when people say
the future of media are the creators
like doing XYZ I'm like oh my god dude
like maybe that's like a new band that
you're assembling but that's not like
the that's not like how everyone's gonna
operate I think you're just you like to
smell your own farts so I don't like I I
think you're just you're out of your
you're out of your depth here that's
that's what I think when I hear stuff
like that
yeah but I think uh nobody means 100 of
people are going to do this when they
say the future is X I think they mean
like a lot certainly sounds that way
yeah but no 100 people don't do anything
today 100 people don't do nine to fives
either so you know not even 80 of people
do nine to five so I think that's kind
of I think it's a given right that's
like a it's a given but it's not sexy
enough you can't say anything is the
future if you say everybody's gonna do
it there's still people who use AOL to
get on the internet like yeah my mom you
know like of course you can't say that
everybody's gonna do it it's it's not a
that's not a realistic thing but I think
it is real to say uh
shit's Gonna Change Trends are going to
shift and you know huge chunks of the
economy or the workforce is going to
look different than it did today because
this whole idea of go to a go to an
office for a nine to five that's also
kind of new and that was also a shift
from what was before so I don't think
that's like just ingrained in human
that's not like biological that's not
physics that's you know society and
economics and a society so it tends to
change
it's not sexy enough to say the future
of work
is this group of people that's a nice
small enough Niche that you can go and
capture market share while also being
big enough to support a multi-billion
dollar company that can return Capital
at a 55 annual return I get it that's
not that's not as catchy it was a
shorthand to the Future yeah
but uh yeah that's cool uh
I have some more topics that I'll say
for later yeah but uh this was a good
one all right that's the pod
thank you
[Music]